breaking news in der tat und darum geht
es vor wenigen minuten ist ein mit
spannung erwartetes hoch brisantes
urteil gefallen da sind die hintergründe
am 23 august 2009 10 da geht ein mann
aus georgien in einem berliner park
spazieren er hat im
tschetschenien krieg gegen russland
gekämpft und lebt jetzt in deutschland
her und plötzlich fallen drei schüsse
der mann bricht tot zusammen und heute
fast zwei jahre später hat das berliner
kammergericht das urteil im sogenannten
tiergarten mordprozess gesprochen und
das ist von höchster brisanz denn es
geht nicht nur um ein heimtückisches
verbrechen in einem park sondern um die
frage ob russland also die regierung
putin diesen mord in auftrag gegeben hat
das ist der vorwurf der deutschen
generalstaatsanwaltschaft gewesen und
das wäre dann russischer staatstheater
auf deutschem boden und das müsste
drastische politische folgen haben in
einer zeit in der die beziehungen zu
russland ohnehin schwer angespannt sind
neben dem ukraine konflikt eine weitere
herausforderung für die neue
bundesregierung die neue auch noch
unerfahrene außenministerin gerade erst
im amt unser reporter peter wilke der es
uns jetzt zugeschaltet er städte vor dem
berliner landgericht peter wir sind
gespannt wie lautet das urteil
ja sandra das urteil ist gerade um 11
uhr 13 gefallen der vorsitzende richter
olaf an aldi hat es ausgesprochen
lebenslänglich der vorwurf des mordes
wurde bestätigt es gilt eine lebenslange
freiheitsstrafe und außerdem wurde die
schwere schuld der tat festgestellt
genauso wie es die bundesanwaltschaft
beantragt hat und damit ist auch
ausgeschlossen dass der täter der
russische staatsbürger war den quasi
kopf nach 15 jahren auf freien fuß
kommen wird eben weil die schwere
schuld festgestellt wurde so hat es die
bundesanwaltschaft eben beantragt weil
man eben den russischen staat als
auftraggeber für diesen mord hinter der
tat vermutet ob das der vorsitzende
richter aus so sieht das ist noch nicht
bekannt geworden das wird jetzt gerade
ausgesprochen denn dieser prozess findet
in dem saal direkt hinter mir statt in
einem hochsicherheitssaal des berliner
landgerichts hier eigentlich verhandelt
das berliner kammergericht das ist aber
ausgewichen auf die gebäude hier weil es
eben hier diesen sicherheits zeit und
weil der angeklagte der jetzt täter auch
in gefahr ist es gab in diesen letzten
zwei jahren seitdem er dann festgenommen
wurde auch schon einen mordanschlag
mitgift aufnehmen
das wird dann die spannende frage sein
ob der richter ist sozusagen auch als
eine politische tat einstuften
russischen staat als auftraggeber
sieht peter wir schauen noch einmal ganz
kurz zurück auf diesen tag als vor knapp
zwei jahren im tiergarten in berlin
dieser mord geschah
ein auftragsmord mitten in berlin
mitten in europa mitten in deutschland
mitten in berlin am hellichten tag ein
solcher ort
der stadt 60 es ist für mich die größte
tragödie weil man mir einen einzigen
bruder genommen hat
er war der wunderbarste mensch den ich
jemals in meinem leben getroffen habe
bild ist auf die spur des in berliner
mordeten mannes gegangen und hat seine
familie in georgien und seine
rechtsanwältin getroffen exklusiv
sprechen die witwe und die schwester des
opfers
der kleine tiergarten in berlin ein mann
ist auf dem weg zum freitagsgebet
unbemerkt nähert sich ihm ein mann auf
einem fahrrad er trägt eine perücke und
einen rucksack
plötzlich zieht er eine waffe und
erschießt den anderen mann von hinten
das opfer ging zu boden der keller feuer
zwei weitere schüsse auf ihn ab und
flüchtet mutmaßlich über die strom
straße in richtung spree er soll die
lessing brücke überquert haben und sein
fahrrad die tatwaffe und die perücke am
holsteiner ufer in die spree geworfen
haben zwei jugendliche zeugen rufen die
polizei die sich gerade in der nähe
befindet
der täter wird kurz darauf von
polizisten gestellt
polizeitaucher holen später die tatwaffe
das fahrrad und die perücke aus der
spree
ich habe ganz zufällig davon erfahren er
hatte auf meine sms nicht geantwortet
ich sah in den nachrichten dass im park
in der nähe jemand getötet wurde und ich
begriff gleich wer es sein könnte
ich rannte zum park dort war viel
polizei und alles war abgesperrt
ich ging gleich zur polizei und zeigte
fotos fragte nach wer dort ist so habe
ich es erfahren
das opfer will im anhang gauche willi
ein 40 jähriger tschetschene aus
georgien von 2001 bis 2005 kämpfte er an
der seite tschetschenischer separatisten
gegen die russischen invasoren seeling
hahn gehörte zur führungsebene der
widerstandskämpfer befehligte 60 mal
nach dem krieg geriet er offenbar ins
visier des putin regimes
2015 hahn ziel eines mordanschlags in
georgien
er überlebt und flüchtet nach
deutschland dort beantragt er 2017 asyl
das wird jedoch im jahr 2019 abgelehnt
nach recherchen des nachrichtenmagazins
der spiegel soll der mörder von selim
kann rango schily 2009/10 ein visum mit
einem gefälschten pass beantragt haben
er reist mit einem schengen-visum nach
frankreich dann nach polen und später
von dort nach deutschland
bei seiner festnahme weist sich der
mutmaßliche täter als war dem so koloss
aus doch die ermittler sind sich sicher
die identität muss gefälscht sein eine
zurückgenommene fahndung aus russland
führt zu der wahren identität des täters
außerdem soll quasi kauf im vorfeld des
mordes engem austausch mit einer
ehemaligen elite einheit des russischen
inlandsgeheimdienstes fsb gewesen sein
der fall sorgt international für
aufsehen hinter dem mord werden
staatliche stellen in russland vermutet
die bundesanwaltschaft klagt heute vor
dem berliner kammergericht den
mutmaßlichen mörder des georgier zählen
kann kann gosch willi an russland weist
jede verwicklung in den mord zurück und
weist wiederum zwei deutsche diplomaten
aus
momentan belastet mich der rufmord an
meinem mann sehr dass man ihn als
terrorist bezeichnet das er kriminell
gewesen sein soll das ist unerhört er
war gegen terror er war der größte
gegner aller terror propaganda
[Musik]
peter wilke du stehst weiterhin vor dem
landgericht in berlin wo gerade das
urteil gefallen ist ja ist der fall denn
damit jetzt geschlossen
ja jetzt gilt erstmal das urteil
natürlich kann die verteidigung auch in
berufung gehen davon dass ist nicht
genau abzusehen ob das passieren wird
der täter schweigt er den ganzen prozess
lang hat nichts dazu gesagt hat auch
nach seiner festnahme eigentlich nur
danach verlangt mit dem mann aus der
russischen botschaft zu sprechen
ansonsten aber in diesem prozess nichts
gesagt und aber also wie es hier vor
gericht weiter geht muss man abwarten
politisch wird das aber auf jeden fall
noch für sprengstoff für diskussionen
sorgen bei eben die rolle des russischen
staates nicht ganz klar ist auch
interessant ist seit 2006 gibt es in
russland ein gesetz was ist dem
präsidenten russlands also in diesem
fall wladimir putin erlaubt
terroristen im ausland zu bekämpfen und
wladimir putin hat eben den ermordeten
hier mehrmals als banditen als
blutrünstigem menschen und eben auch als
terror als als blutrünstigem menschen
bezeichnet dieser mann wurde in russland
als terrorist angesehen insofern ist ein
mord durch den russischen staat ist
wahrscheinlich soll ein auftragsmord
durch den russischen staat
mit den ersten einordnungen nach diesem
urteil in berlin fiel dann dafür